Good evening, sir.
Good evening. Good evening, sir.
Good evening, sir. Good evening, Al.
Good evening, sir.
Good evening, sir. Good evening, Al. Good evening.
So sir, today, uh, we'll recording
In progress,
Sunil.
Yeah. Today we'll, uh, release the assignment.
Uh, they have to do one assignment Okay.
Coding based assignment. Okay.
And we'll give two weeks time, sir.
Uh, because they have to build a n and CNN networks
No problem.
Yeah. So that we will do,
and, uh, according to the calendar this Saturday, Saturday,
they should write this, uh, uh, mid-semester examination.
Okay. But some of them were requesting
to keep it on next Monday.
No problem. No problem. Yeah.
So that is how We, we can,
we can do that and there's no problem.
Yes. Yeah,
that should be fine.
So
Actually, I'm not sure who requested for Monday.
I thought weekend is always better for exams,
but anyway, it won't work for everybody.
Uh, right. So there's always different preferences. Monday,
Monday is a starting week, and it's always hectic.
Yeah. Especially like, uh, evening time, right?
Like while, yeah. We are able to join the classes anyway,
Next, next Saturday.
I'm not sure who requested the change
or not. They are impacted
The last, last class.
Some of them were requesting, that's why
No. Saturday first
classes from, uh, 9:00 AM uh,
we are working on, some
of us are working on Saturday as well.
That's why I requested sir
to keep it in the evening session.
Yeah. Like Saturday evening, maybe we,
if we can plan out, that'll also help.
Yes, sir. Saturday would be fine because it's working.
Okay. But in the evening time, you want Yes. Yes.
Saturday evening is better, sir.
Let us do a Saturday evening.
Okay. So morning we'll have class evening
you will write exam, right? Yes, yes.
Yes, sir. Yes. Anyway,
we have a literature review class at 7 45.
So we can have from uh, six, probably from seven
to 7 45, we can have the exam.
Yeah.
Mid, maybe longer duration a week.
Uh, that's what at least it'll go up to
One hour.
One hour Or six 30.
You can start, sir.
Okay. Yeah, that can be,
but we are to announce well in advance
because some others may say, you know, on
that day I had some other engagement. Yes,
Sir. Actually, I have
made up some other plans, uh, for that.
No Problem. Problem now. So I plan
for the Saturday morning, so yeah,
Saturday morning, some of them have off.
So the problem is the 17th, uh, of the, the Saturday that,
that is a festival week, sir.
So the, probably people are being, uh,
busy traveling or something like that.
I, I'm not sure 10th is the right type this coming Saturday.
So, but, uh, coming Saturday, what is that issue, Sunil?
Well, I, we planned during the class hour we can keep,
because that is, anyway, the, uh,
that is a fixed slot when
we have to connect. Correct? Correct.
That's right. Uh, If we deviate from the slot, then uh,
someone would be having something else
and then we will not be able to, uh, yeah.
That is the main thing I'm seeing.
Yeah. Um,
maybe on Saturday we can have then those who cannot date.
Uh, you can have another one for those people
who cannot attend on Saturday.
Mm. Also,
Maybe Monday seems a lot.
I'm okay, but, uh, you people have to agree for Monday,
Monday, Monday's. Okay.
Monday is okay, sir.
The weekday, first day of the week,
that's what they're Monday's likely busy.
Sir, I do have client calls in the evening, correct?
Correct.
That is decide then, uh, properly
where there should not be any confusion.
Mm, yes. There is, uh,
Per, uh, MLP, sir,
where it was conducted on Saturdays on the regular schedule,
but, uh, since it was working and some of us missed,
and the evening you have enabled the same thing.
We did it, sir. That way if we can manage,
it's okay, sir, for us.
Okay.
So evening time, 6 32.
Seven 30, some of you are not there, right?
Otherwise we could have kept it in the,
so we'll keep at the, uh, regular time, sir.
Then we'll see how many of them are not able to write.
We can enable for them at some other recording
Program.
Yeah. Yeah. Im CQ type, uh, exam, right?
Yes. Yes, yes. Okay. So when is the
Exam, sir?
Saturday. Saturday Coming Saturday, sir. Yes. Yeah.
10th January. Yeah,
10th of January.
Is it okay to all of you? Yes, sir. Should be fine.
Yes, sir. Yes, sir. Yes, sir. Yes. Yes, sir.
Only in timing, sir.
Uh, we should not worry too much about that, sir.
What is the syllabus like till this class or
Until the last tell till this class?
Yes. So, uh, shall we start? Yes, sir. We can start.
So last session I was traveling.
Uh, no, it was so nice here.
I did not tell what I, I spoke, I think, uh, Dr.
Sun has clarified I think all those things again.
Um, so, um, I think, uh, all of you should appreciate, uh,
know the Conversional network and, um, its effectiveness.
Um, see, the big bang for deep learning came through
demonstration of CNN in ImageNet classification task, as I,
I, uh, mentioned in the opening remark.
Now we'll see some architectures which came as a result of
that, and which changed the status
of the whole computer vision domain.
Now, with the, if you go to the computer vision discipline,
there is nothing, which doesn't start with the computer.
This one, uh, CNN, like that, the, it has become synonymous
with, uh, a computer vision fee.
The first one is, uh, now, which they, um,
published a papers called ImageNet classification
with the deep conation NEUR Networks came in that nips, uh,
2012 proceedings.
The first author is Alex,
and later people started calling mostly
as AlexNet instead of CNN.
Uh, see, for the first time,
they demonstrated a significant improvement in performance
in image net classification task.
I think, uh, I briefly mentioned that.
Uh, it is, uh, the task, it's a open challenge,
grand challenge for the whole world community working
on computer vision.
Uh, uh, the, uh, they have 1.2 million
that say well lack high resolution images, uh,
in ImageNet, uh, I think large, uh,
LLI think L-S-V-R-C, I don't know the expansion
that L-S-V-R-C 2010, uh, contest, uh,
which need to classify.
Of course, out of these images, they have done training
and testing, uh, segregation.
There is a thousand class,
a thousand different objects are to be classified.
A thousand class classification problem in element term,
let us treat is a thousand class classification problem.
And, um, now people are, um,
very, since they very standard benchmarking across the
world, who is who in the, uh,
conclusion field participate in that to
benchmark their methods.
So here, uh, earlier people used
to use some other traditional image processing
and computer vision methods.
This, again, this AlexNet is also from pro a Hinton group
who proposed the, the, uh, training
of a deep learning models earlier.
We demonstrate for Feedforward in our network.
Now, this Alex and the team, his students, they told,
why can't we apply this conventional network
for this ImageNet classification task For that,
what they did is they, um, they participated in 2012,
whereas they took the previous biennial challenge
2010 dataset.
They took 1.2 million image and thousand different classes.
And on the test date test data, uh,
different systems are benchmarked.
One with the top one performance means, uh, the
recognized class or hypothesized class by the model matches
with the target class in the first position.
That is the top one. Anywhere in the top five positions.
It can be either first position second
or up to fifth position.
In the top five, the found top one error rates
to be 37.5, whereas the top five error rate
to be 17% naturally, you know, you are
top one is always come, you know, uh, difficult.
That's why 37.5
and any within top five is 17% better than state of the art.
Okay? We'll see that in the next, uh, uh, table. Okay?
Uh, this, that conversional network that
RiNo had 60 million parameters for the first time.
They were talking about such big number
of parameters in 2012 and five conversion layers
and, uh, three fully connected layers.
After five conversion layers,
there are three fully connected layers.
And final layer has a thousand output notes with out max
4,000 plus classification.
Okay? And once they fine tuned
and tested the system on 2010, a variant of that was
submitted as a system for 2012 dataset.
And, uh, we achieved a winning top five test category rate
of 15.3% rather than second best system,
which is a non deep learning based method was at 26.2%.
Okay? And this caught the attention of the whole community.
Okay? So, but what is the motivation?
One is the performance. That's now a step change.
You can see now, just like the acoustic modeling paper I was
telling about 10% improvement came 40 rate from 27 brought
down to 18 or 19.
Same way. This image net classification,
non deep learning method was given 26.2.
These people gave 15.3.
Again, this is a breakthrough result, okay?
And, uh, but the, the hypothesis for them when they gave get
mm, got such good performance was,
uh, they justified the use of Conversional network for that.
If you want to learn, know, uh, thousands of objects
from millions of image, millions of images, you need a,
a model with a large learning capacity.
That means to say it ingestion capacity is very high.
Uh, when you have millions of images
and you want to learn thousands
of information about thousands of objects,
your network should be, you know, the capacity
of the network should be big enough to crunch those images
and learn the discriminatory information that is available
among the different objects.
And they found that CNN can be one such thing
compared to the freefall network.
Even though freefall network, you, um, increase the number
of layers, um, like deep feed for networks we do,
um, they, they found
that this commercial network will have a
more ingestion capacity compared to, uh, the same number
of layers defeat for the network.
Okay? And further there, they told no,
you can control this learning capability
or ingestion capability by wearing the depth and breadth.
That means, say, increase the number of commercial layer
and also increase the width of the condition layer.
So both you can control.
And since you're using that filter
and, uh, no, uh, you can, uh, compared to
every node connecting to a,
every node in the following layer,
which is the basic philosophy of, uh, feed four network,
uh, CNNs will have much few connections and parameters
and easy to try.
Okay? Of course, since,
even though the number
of connections are limited in compared to the feed four
because it's not fully connected, like fit for network,
but still we are processing in two dimensional fashion.
It is prohibitively expensive, uh, know, uh,
to apply on high resolution images.
But of course, luckily these GPU paired with large set,
like imagine it facilitated no training, interestingly,
large, uh, dimension,
conventional network without severe war fitting.
See, earlier also, I told no the, the basic concept
of commission network came in late 1980s
or early 1990s, even though the basic philosophy
and, uh, some tie like studies were demonstrated for CNN,
but never able to demonstrate its capability
for the first time in this AlexNet,
they demonstrated the true capability
of the commercial method, but that came
because we have large variety data set
and also GP used to try in such big network.
Um, this is a pictorial representation
taken from that figure.
It has no, this is the input image.
There are five conventional layer, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, followed
by that three, uh, fully connected layers,
like a feed forward network
and thousand class classification problem.
Is there, okay?
So totally it contains eight layers.
First five are conversion, remaining are fully connected,
and the output is of the last fully connected layer.
This thousand plus, uh, uh,
classification is the sort match function.
Is there typically some details about the architecture.
The first conversion layer, uh, filters are 2 24,
class 2 24, cross three, three means RGB image
input image with 96 kernels, okay?
Of size 11, class 11, the three, you forget.
This three is for the RGB.
So input image of 2, 2 24, cross 2 24
into three means RGB.
The kernel size usually in the first convention was 11
across 11, with a shift of stride of four pixels.
Every four pixels, we are going to shift anyway,
so we don't have to be really, uh,
know, remember all these things.
What is important is in the first convolution layer,
the use of 96 different kernels, uh,
of size 11, class 11, to extract the information.
So that is what, uh, uh, uh, uh, to be said
similarly, the second con conversion layer
has 2 56 kernels of size five class file.
Um, then, um,
then third conversion layer has 3 84 kernels.
Three class three class 2 56.
Uh, then third conversion layer has 3 84 kernels,
and fifth convention, fourth, fifth convention,
2 56 kernels.
So like these, um, you,
you can have kernels
or filters designed for different, uh, dimensions.
So accordingly know our different purpose.
You can extract different variety of information from there.
Same. That is what we discuss at earlier.
But what is, what you have to appreciate is, uh, 96
filters means the same input layer is processed with, uh,
96, uh, uh, different filter 96 times.
I'm processing the, uh, filter.
Similarly, 2 56 times I'm processing the, uh,
in the second conversion layer, 3 84 and so on, okay?
And, uh, fully connected layers are four,
4,096 neurons each other.
So, so essentially, uh, the depth
that five conversion layers
and each number of, uh, in each layer, large number
of kernels resulted in
that 60 million parameters totally in the network.
Okay? So that's what, um, here, see, this is that system
on 2010, when the user until that point,
the state of the art system was one, was on sparse coding,
which is a non neural network based approach.
Top 1% was 47 point, uh, one, and the top five was 28.2.
Similarly, the, another method was C plus, um, FW,
uh, FF vs maybe four year vectors.
I don't know that part. 45.7, 25.7.
And this is the system they observed initially when they're
put, uh, 37.57 70.
Okay? So they found the,
on the previous year, previous challenge data set,
the AlexNet achieved significantly better performance
compared to the, the top one
and top two systems, which have won, uh,
awards in the previous challenge.
Okay? So this is, you know, uh, six spark coding models
and, uh, this is for Fisher vectors that have fees
with blue last factor, something we don't have to bother.
What is important is appreciating that no,
there is a significant jump in the performance that then
what they did is, okay, this model seems to be working
then no for 2012 dataset
because they don't know the result yet.
Only test release without the, uh, no, uh,
what we call key for evaluating the performance.
What they did was on the current data set,
which they're supposed to submit the system,
they did some minor variations.
What they did was this one, CNN is that 40.7,
18.2, uh, this is nothing but this system, 27.5
and 17.0, of course,
after evaluation, this is what they,
the performance they got.
Okay? Then the AlexNet, what I explained
for 2010 dataset, uh,
top five error percent was 18.2, which is 17.2.
On the previous year, dataset 17%, maybe
because the, the complexity
of the dataset would've increased.
Then what they did was they did
five different CNNs were client on the same dataset,
five different side, maybe wearing the parameters in terms
of kernels and all those things.
That means, say essentially on the same dataset,
you are modeling five different CNNs
and average the predictions of five similar CNNs,
it gives 16.4%, okay?
Um, say one CNN, you train five different CNNs
with the different kernels, maybe different number
of kernels, okay?
And just to average those predictions,
and that gives 16.44%, no, roughly 1.8%, uh,
implement in the performance.
Then, uh, they all, these are all,
all just an experimental study.
They were trying, they did okay, instead of five layers,
let me have one more, uh, sixth con conversion layer,
it gave an error rate of 16.6% instead
of five different CNNs and training.
I train only one CNN with six layers. Now it gives 16 point.
Um, this one,
then they did the aging predictions of, uh,
two CNNs pre-trained on the entire, uh, fall 2011,
this one, and with file LA layers, he gave me 15,
15.3%.
Okay? That means to say seven, uh, neural networks,
which is five CNNs one class, one CNN class, another one,
CNN, with extra six layers.
The average predictions of all these things that resulted in
that seven CNNs that gave 15.3%, of course, these are all,
no, just, uh, experimentally, they're trying something
and combine, uh,
this is not any great research point of view.
The first great breakthrough is this only top error rate
of 18.2%,
and the second best system at that point was 26.2,
that shift plus FES, whereas these people got 15.3.
That is the, you know,
first time the whole world notice about that, okay?
Uh, that image, uh, net plus challenge,
they took note of CNNs
and then now was know people started, uh, using only CNNs
for ImageNet classification task.
Then after that, uh, then
in 2014 challenge
after two years, what they did was, see here,
they tried a maximum of two six layers, then
the same, uh, know the, as the next extension of that,
they felt no, since I can try with breadth
and depth, they felt, so any, any doubt
for this AlexNet there, one of the very important, uh,
um, no breakthrough model.
Yes, sir. Rish, yes, sir.
So top one means we are taking one test, uh,
sample only, and top means
When I suppose it's, it's predicts, say, class two.
Now the given for test data, it predicts as class two.
There are a thousand classes.
Suppose it predicts as class two,
and your target output is also class two in the
top one matching only.
Then it is top one.
Suppose it predicts as class two, okay?
But the actual class is, uh, class three
or something, suppose based
around their prediction probability or something.
If I arrange their prediction con,
let us say confidence based on the confidence,
I arrange them from ascending highest confidence
to lowest confidence.
Okay? And the highest confidence one is top one, okay?
Yes, sir. And in the top five highest confidences,
if it comes, whether it in the first position, second
or fifth position, that is top five.
Yes. Perfect. Okay, thank you, sir. Yeah.
So, but what is known to be appreciated, uh, see
after they demonstrated in 2006, uh, about,
uh, possible to try and deep neur network.
And the second thing is in the speech case,
acoustic modeling, they demonstrated in 2010
or so, one group,
but of course, publication finally came in 2012,
but 2009 10, they were doing that.
Then came this 2012 result,
where in the imaginal classification, using those
who are using DP four network, this is using, uh, uh,
uh, CNN.
Then, uh,
after that, the next, uh, breakthrough came here is
they felt in the AlexNet
they stopped at six layers.
And, you know, they played with the number
of kernels, all those things.
It's more in terms of breadth, then this Karen
and team the field, can we
explore the depth aspect of CNN?
Okay, I, I will not, I'll keep all
of the breadth, everything same.
Only I go on increasing the number of layers.
How does it affect the performance
of same image net classification task.
So that is the goal of this VGG net.
That is called as VGG net, very deep con, uh,
convolution letter for large scale, uh, image recognition.
They call it as in short, we call it as VGG net,
investigate the effect of CNN depth on its accuracy in large
scale image recognition task.
Um, so they carried out a thorough evaluation
of the CNN networks
of increasing depth using an architecture
with very small conversional.
There, we told no conversion filter breadth.
If you see here, uh, 11 crust, 11 five crust five, okay?
So like this, they had, whereas, um, here
they just fixed it.
A very small con conversion filter, only three crust, three,
three crust, three, uh, conversion filters.
And, um, uh,
but the depth went from 16 to 19 layers, 16
to depth 19 layers.
Okay? Then again, no,
this became a top performance in, uh, the 2000,
uh, 14 ImageNet classification.
Uh, and the representation also generalized well for other,
other states where the achieved state of the art result.
Okay? So, uh, of course,
if you see the difference compared to AlexNet is, uh,
several attempts were made to improve AlexNet.
Uh, for example, in, uh, 2013,
the utiliz smaller receptive window size
and smaller trade off first conversion layer, okay?
Uh, means first commercial layer, they use it instead
of elevens 11, the reducer to the tried.
And, uh, also instead of four as a tried, they reduce it.
All those things, no typical experimental research they did.
So they also tried training
and testing that was densely over whole image
and over multiple scales.
And, uh, there,
whereas the VGG net addressed another important aspect
of commercial network architecture only depth, okay?
Fix other parameters of architecture.
I don't play with number of filters
and stride of the filter.
Uh, all those things I don't do.
I will keep very, uh, minimum possible windows sizes,
three cross three conversion filters in all the layers
go on, increasing the depth.
Okay? So that is what, uh, they, uh, experimented.
So input conversion networks as standard 2 24,
cross 2 24 RGB image.
They use filters with very small receptive field three,
cross three, and the con slide is fixed at every pixel.
And, uh, no, uh,
these are all some small things and,
and the three fully connected layers,
first two have 4 96 channels.
And the third one is this,
this segment fully connected remains same as ate, okay?
And they tried no different com configuration.
They tried configuration.
No, the depth of the configuration increases from
left A to the right.
E the left leftmost is A,
and the rightmost is e different configuration.
Suppose I consider, uh, a
configuration exploration,
11 weight layers are there, okay?
Uh, whereas, uh, uh, e if I take
19 layers are there from 11 to 19 day experiment, right?
Then input images, uh, 2 24 cross,
2 24, you,
you can see now all conation 3, 3, 3, they have kept
that means to say the filter size are three, cross three,
um, the other one is the 64, uh,
different kernels.
And, uh, 64, and again, no, these are all 64 case they kept.
Then 1 28, 2 56, um,
512.
And uh, so then finally
you have fully connected layer.
So this is how from the input layer,
it goes like this, okay?
You have, um, 64 cross, uh,
64 filter in the case 1 28, 1 2, 56, 500, 12
point 12, and max full.
This sort max is there.
This is, so one case is 11, uh, uh,
11 layer conversion layer followed
by three fully connected layers.
This LRNI have forgotten. I have to see that.
Then, uh, the B is 13 layers followed
by fully connected layer, 16 layer fully connected layers.
Okay? And, um, uh, 16, again,
fully connected layers and 19 layers.
See the, the number of parameters, uh,
is one 33 million parameters for, uh, A
and A LRN and 1 33 for B 1 34, like this.
Number of million parameters change, uh,
in spite of this large depth.
19 layers, no, the number
of weights they found out computed, no,
not greater than the number
of weights in the more shallow network
with large con conversion layer width and receptive fields.
That is the advantage. Uh, no, uh, they're shown.
Um, now these are the, um,
so local response ation, LRN means,
so suppose the performance
or like this for ea, which has 11 layers,
the top one validation error was, uh, uh,
29.6.
Top five validation error was 10.4.
This is not tested validation error. You can see this.
10.4 is already bigger than smaller than error is smaller
than earlier, 15.3.
So finally, if you go to that E, they got
around 8.7 and uh, eight also.
Okay, of course, this 2 56, uh, 2012, there is some,
um, um, uh,
some modification.
They do, uh, classification error, decrease
with increasing the depth from 11 to, uh, uh, 19 layers.
That is A to E. You can see the classification error decre,
uh, decreasing, and, uh, C that is same depth.
C uh, uh, performs worse than deep.
Let me see. So here, um,
if they have done convolution one also,
there is somewhere they have put convolution one, uh,
that performed poorer than convolution three.
That's what they're telling here.
Uh, three, one cross,
one convolution layers performs
worse than convolution layer.
That means to say, as a filter, minimum three,
cross three is required
to exploit some neighborhood property.
That's what the meaning of this one.
Additionally, non-linearity helps. C is better than B.
However, important to capture spatial context
by using con conversion filters.
Non-trivial knee is better than C.
That's what, uh, they're told.
One is this multi-scale training.
This is, see if you see this not 2 56 comma 512.
Uh, so, uh, this instead of fixed size images,
they trained with multiple size images,
2 56 to 512.
That's what multiscale training,
which training image is individually rescaled
by randomly sampling, yes,
from a certain range somewhere from 2 56 to 512.
So since the objects in images can be of different size,
but sure to take this scaling approach, that is
what they have shown here, multi-scale
that give the best performance during testing,
you use whatever the size you get.
But training, multi-scale training you do,
it gives the best performance,
that eight validation error, okay?
And that's what they're told.
Multi-scale training helps in improving the performance.
Now, um, again, um, uh,
multiple test scales, they did
and, uh, know, uh, during testing also they try
to change with this.
So this, this table has, uh,
where doing testing also you test it multiple scale
that also tries to help in some way.
That's what running a model over several rescaled version
of testing made, followed by aging the result, uh, aging,
those result 2 56, 3 84 5 12, get the result
and combine it our it.
So that is nothing but a scale they call.
So that is what they got,
and those are all, uh, uh, essentially validation error.
But you see the final result here, uh,
top one performance validation error, uh,
is 24.7.
Top five validation error is 7.5,
and top five test is 7.3.
Similarly, this is multi crop and dense evaluation.
If you see it gave to 6.8 performance, combine the output
of several models by aging their soft max class per this
simple averaging of the, uh, the classification output.
So this is a significant improvement over,
and here, except that multis scaling, uh,
only the major contribution is in terms
of increasing the depth, where they stopped at six layers.
They went up to 19 layers here,
and this is the summary they have done.
See, the, um, 2012,
this result we have seen earlier, 16.4 was the result,
but people tried on different, sorry,
tried on different things, uh, try to improve that AlexNet,
starting from 16.1, they achieve,
but final result, VGG they showed is 6.8, uh, uh,
improvement in the performance, which is again, no,
in two years span of time, they brought it down from 16.42,
about six, no, 6.8, which is again, you know,
where people were hovering around, uh, 27, 26.
For a long time, they brought it down to 6.8%. Okay?
So this is the, you know, VGG network
where in terms of, uh, um, increasing the depth
of the network up to 19 layers, even with the,
not breadth wise, very simple thing,
but they're able to demonstrate signal.
The depth also contributes.
Two, learning the information, learning
and modeling the information.
That is what it says here compared to AlexNet.
The three times the depth, okay?
Apart from using kernels, filters of different sizes
and number increase, number of filters, uh, you just, uh,
how increase the depth there also,
you can significantly improve the performance of the system.
That is what this, uh, paper demonstrated
came in ICLR 2050.
And also they found that no, even though this ImageNet uh,
uh, uh, classifier
he's used here on training the image classification, one
of the biggest, uh, advantage they showed
with this VG Gnet was
this became a pre-trained model like thing.
Now, once you have a pre-trained model,
any other image classification task, now you can find,
tune this model and achieve significantly good
performance performance.
Actually, after seeing this result, only it started, uh,
you know, uh,
hitching the community working on recurrent neural networks
and its variances that can we come up
with an equivalent model like CNN for sequence modeling,
where I will be able to train using the available data,
very large pre-trained model.
Then I can use that model for, um, for fine tuning,
using some small data center.
That is where the, that resulted in the proposal of
after nearly two years, two, three years,
this transformer architecture.
Okay? So that is the, that is the third.
Now, the biggest first thing is significant
improvement in the performance.
The second thing that showed was,
um, you can use this pre-trained model on any other
ImageNet class where you don't have that many images,
and that is what that, uh,
pre-trained model concept became very prevalent,
and people started looking at in the other neural network
architecture also, which is also one of the major motivation
for transformer architecture.
Any questions? Any questions?
So I will go to the next model, what is called resnet,
the failure, what happens now?
Okay, 19 layers. They have stopped it.
Can I go on further increasing the depth of the network,
what, what will happen?
Supposedly they have shown threefold increase.
There is a significant improvement in the performance.
What will happen if I increase further?
Okay, that's way,
but they found that when they further increases the depth
of the network, it became difficult for them to train.
Okay? Uh, that is where they brought a new, uh,
concept called deep learning for training deeper,
deeper networks than the VGG net, okay?
Sub substantial deeper than V net, okay?
So what they did was, uh, instead of, uh,
no training the given function,
uh, try to train the network to capture the residual means.
The residual means, suppose I apply input, uh,
to some block of neural network.
Say FFX is input and say, YFX is the output
after few layers in that block of neur network
after say five layers, then YFX, now I am the,
the in between layer.
What it learns is the mapping from input F FX to YFX.
Instead of that you take the difference between YFX
and uh, FFX and try to learn that difference.
Only that is how they formulate.
We'll see that in the next step.
So accordingly, no, uh, uh,
since you are using the difference only for learning,
that means to say lot of correlated information is removed
only what is very important
for learning only I will use essentially, no,
when I take the residual part
or the difference, then lot of, um,
correlated part is removed.
So accordingly with, uh, you can better lung only,
that required discriminatory information.
So that is where the resident networks, they're easy
to optimize, can gain accuracy from
considerable increasing depth.
Okay? Um, they know, they explain, no,
the learning better networks is easy as stacking more layer,
I go on stacking more layer.
What happens, what they found is I think somewhere this
figure is there, suppose a 20 layer network is there
training error left and is the test error.
And with the 20 layer network, this is
how the training error decreases as it, it raises increase.
Whereas a 56 layer network already,
the training error is at a higher level.
That means to say as you increase the depth of the network,
it is not able to model that information in
what is expected.
Uh, uh, uh,
as was visualized in VGG net, they stopped at 19 layer.
But beyond that, this is how the whole, uh,
value training error shifts up,
showing even testing error also is like this.
So ideally what is required is
as you increase the 56 layers,
the training error should go much
below the 20 layer network.
That is the very purpose here.
Then only you're capturing better information
and this is what they observed.
So that is where I think these things are.
There, you can read it.
They brought what is called a re risk net architecture.
Uh, they address this degradation problem.
When you increase the depth of the network,
the finding error increases
and testing error increases using a concept called, uh, uh,
deep presidial learning framework.
Okay? Uh, instead of what that it is
decide underlying mapping function is a CHF X.
Then the let the stack nonlinear fit
along the mapping function.
FFX is D defined HFX minus X. This is the case.
For example, X is you're applying as input,
and this is F, FX is the mapping that is achieved.
Uh, so, so when you are forcing through that,
and suppose I have a bypass here, which is the same,
X is input is given to here at this point is FFX plus X.
This is X goes through this.
When it comes to here, the output functionality, the F of X
plus this one, this is the basic building block
of a residual network.
Okay? So this, um, then
suppose you, you, you want to, uh,
learn this mapping function HFX.
Then, uh, instead of trying to try that is
what they were doing earlier, instead of this,
let this stack non-linear layer fit another mapping
function, FFX, which is defined as HFX minus X.
Okay? Then the original mapping function will recast into
FFX plus X.
So essentially, this is what I have to learn,
but I will define an alternative function, FFX,
which is defined as HFX minus X.
So accordingly, this will be equivalent to
FFX plus X.
So on that basis, they brought this
layer building block, okay?
Then what happens is, see at a very,
as you increase the depth, uh, you are passing
that input too far, far fast forwarding that input
through short identity network.
So as a result of that, no,
that information is available at the advanced
layers also to learn.
So conceptually, that is how it is able
to hold the training error,
reduce the training error as we go further.
So the shortcut connections simply perform identity mapping,
and their outputs are added
to the output of the stacked layer.
Okay? So,
and also the shortcut networks neither add extra parameter
nor computational complexity.
And, uh, then as a result,
these extremely deep pial networks are
very easy to optimize.
But the, uh,
counterpart blind text blind nets simply stacking the layer
exhibit higher training error when the depth increases.
So that how no, the deep Pial network can easily enjoy the
accuracy gains by greatly increasing the depth produc,
the results substantially better than the previous
network VGG network.
So the simple plan is you go on increasing without
any residual connection.
Like this one is VGG 19 layer, case
36 layer network network, okay?
The then same 34 layers,
but this connections are there, okay?
And this is how, for example, plain 18 layers is
that CN color, and the plain 34 layer is this one.
You can see now as I increase the number of layers,
the training error also shifts up.
Whereas if I use res RESNET 18 layers, is
that CN color, resnet 34 layers, you can see
that error is lower than this.
That means to say we are able to, uh,
now control the training error as we increase the depth
of the result, and they showed the performance improvement.
Now, 18 layers per plain text is 27.94,
whereas 34 layers is 28.54,
whereas if I use resnet same 18, 24, 27, it comes
to 25 top 1%, uh, performance.
Okay? That means to say with the help
of residual connections, I'm able to, uh, reduce the error,
then do a better learning,
and that is what they have shown here.
VGG net 16 layers, 9.33%,
and, uh, no applying, uh, 34% was 10%,
then rest next 34 3 was 7.4,
and they increase the depth to 1 52 layers,
that it came to 5.7.
Okay? So that is how, uh, they, they showed
by including the depth, by using the PL l connection,
you're able to avoid the difficulties of learning
as is there in the client network
and, uh, further increase the performance.
So finally, uh, so all these three innovations
from VGG net, 7.3, rest net,
what they gave us, 3.57, uh,
which is an ensemble of, uh, you know, uh, multiple,
uh, renet networks that did it and use 3.57.
So you can imagine now starting from somewhere from 16.4
in about four years time, they're able to come to 3.57,
which is almost no, uh,
significant improvement in the performance.
So, uh, just to, uh, know, summarize, uh,
the journey that had taken place somewhere from 26.2
where people are hovering for many decades.
Uh, first breakthrough came 15.3, the steeper
reduction in the error within next two years.
They got it 6.8 with resnet, they got it to, uh, 3.4.
This is AlexNet used to demonstrate the capability of CNN,
and, uh, the vnet is CNN with the depth aspect of CNN.
These rest is, uh, exploiting the cons,
the concept of residual networks,
rather than learning the given signal,
you learn the residual, okay?
That is where, you know, they, uh, demonstrated
such significant improvement in the performance.
I think that rest is strict here in the, uh,
computer vision task, and people started then,
then people started using the CNN in all other tasks also.
So I'll stop it here.
I, I suggest all of you should read these three papers just
for their now, great, uh, result,
breakthrough results, they got it.
One is that the ate another VG net,
the third one is the resnet,
and these are being extensively used
as a great architecture now, uh, even
for any other CNN task also.
So I'll stop it here if you have any questions, I will take,
otherwise, I'll request CN uh, Sunil, you want to,
Uh, yes, sir. Yes,
sir. Any questions from anyone,
Sir? Um, quick
question.
So I wonder if, uh, they measured any, um, like, uh,
error rate for, for humans in comparison?
Um, um, course.
Ah, okay. So, uh, maybe I, uh,
that I am not sure.
I'm not focused from that.
T maybe Sunil, if you are red,
you can tell I have not used it from look, see, for example,
um, uh, just to know,
guess answer I'll give from my speech knowledge,
speech processing knowledge in case of speech processing,
suppose equivalently, I take speech recognition,
even subjective, human subjective error in, uh,
recognizing the words is less than 5%, okay?
In a practical setting task, right? Three, two, maybe.
This also, you may have to see that papers read.
Maybe this is also a human level performance only that 3%.
Yeah, I, I I would assume that humans also would error.
Ah, yeah, definitely.
See that is expected, no,
because these are all practical image data sets, right?
There's no control environment here.
Maybe it is comparable to that,
but what is important though, this gave such a solid, uh,
support for deep learning models
and also it motivated this transformer on
the other architectures.
Suddenly overnight, this computer vision became so fancy,
uh, area of research for so many researchers,
because now they have a pre-trained model, uh, like VG net,
AlexNet, renet people started using them as
and started playing with them, right?
That is also resulted in transformer
and then resulted in LLMs foundation model.
So many things came. That's how in next decade.
Thank you, sir. Yeah, yeah, thank you.
So any of you,
Uh, sir, I have one que query on this
both VGG and resonate.
Sir. Sir, if you show this both VG, G
and RESNET architecture saying in the resnet,
we are directly copying the input in, uh, input data
and giving and bypassing the several blocks
and giving it to the one predefined block, okay?
So what motivated them to go
for this kind of arrangement, sir?
Between the VGG and resnet? Yeah.
Uh, no one is when they simply increase the VGG, uh,
VGG architecture, they doubled it and increased it.
No, the training error was becoming higher.
That is that client network they were telling. Yes.
So in place of that, they, they felt, see instead of,
uh, training, uh, trying to learn the mapping function
for the whole signal, you remove the redundancy
and try to learn only the residual part.
That is where the FFX plus X came into picture.
That, that if HFX is to be learned,
learned in a block of layers, yes,
I will define FFX is defined as HFX minus X.
Okay? And that is what I wanna learn in the network.
So first I learned that
and connect a short circuit there to become FFX plus X,
which is effectively learning HFX able
to explain better, yes,
Which means that we are not fully learning that, uh,
all the features we'll learn, uh, some part of the features
and, uh, since, because we are getting input,
so then we learn the other parts.
So in that way, we are able to reduce
the trainable parameters.
Let, let me tell like this, suppose X is given as input
to a deep learning model.
Yes. And I'm supposed to learn
through a, a sequence of layers.
I'm supposed to learn, learn the mapping function. HFX. Yes.
So instead of learning HFX, what I will learn is FFX,
which is defined as HFX minus X.
Okay, sir. Okay.
And that I call it as residual, okay?
Because I'm taking that mapping function minus the input
that I call it as given name as residual.
Yes. Now that FFX I'm trying to learn through the block
of layers, but at the output point, I require still HFX.
Yes. But if I require HFX, what is the subtracted sub?
That's where FX plus XI do, maybe Sunil, you have explaining
earlier, maybe you please correct me if
I, I think wrong there.
Uh, no, sir. I, I think this is the same thing.
I guess maybe you can try you once explain from your side
maybe more clarification,
Michael. Yeah, I, I'll do that,
sir. I'll do that.
Maybe I'll take them maybe a little bit
of a practical way, uh, one by one then
For all these things, huh?
Yeah. Yes. Thank you.
I have one question.
So sir, uh, this, uh, uh,
degradation problem is the right, like, uh,
is this degradation problem is the same as, uh, uh,
vanishing de gradient, or is it different? Uh,
It's same as vanishing gradient only, same
as vanishing gradient only.
Effectively, that only, okay, um,
yeah, fine.
Thank you. The Sunil, please.
Yeah, yeah. Yes. Is is it audible, sir? Oh,
Yeah, yeah, audible.
Okay. Okay, thank you.
Alright, so I'll protect my
screen just a second.
Okay. So hopefully my screen is visible, so
Yes, yes, Yes, yes.
Thank you. So the plan, what I have is that, uh, I
want to show you some, uh, implementation of
what Sarah just explained, uh,
and of the, one of the,
the networks like Sarah explained about the AlexNet, uh,
about the vvcs in net TenneT, I,
I'll show you today about the VVC 16,
maybe going further, uh, possible.
I'll also show you about the resident,
and then that time it'll be more clear.
So, uh, but uh, before that, uh,
before jumping into the coding directly, uh, there is,
there is a concept of transfer learning,
what we studied in the, in the previous course itself,
machine learning paradigms, okay?
And now it'll make more sense to all of you that why
that transfer learning is required.
I guess you have already seen that with the, uh,
AlexNet VGG six, uh, VGZ, as well as different versions
for the VGG, as well as this resnet the number of parameters
for growing, okay?
Although it had shown the better performance, uh,
but then the number of para parameters were growing, okay?
So if you can recall from our previous course, uh,
we, we had seen this particular slide,
that's why I have kept it as it is.
Uh, just wanted you to recall this one, that, uh,
in the, in the training, uh,
if you will start training these networks,
these bigger networks from the scratch all the time,
then it is going to be expensive.
And many, many times you will not be able
to implement it also in your local system.
Okay? Why? Because, uh,
training such a bigger network from the scratch would,
would requires a large labeled data set
for every new task, right?
For example, uh, this ImageNet, uh,
on which this, uh, LX net,
which this VG networks were trained, they used
around 1.2 millions of images.
Now, that was the size
of the images on which these networks were trained.
Now, all the time, when you will start training such a big
network, you may not have, uh,
such a large data set available, okay?
You may have a data set in hundreds or in thousands, right?
10,000, 50,001 lag, right?
But then having data all the time in millions,
like 1.2 millions images with thousand classes, that is,
that is, uh, that is, that is not,
uh, the case all the time.
What you will have, okay?
That is the first problem, uh, in training such a large, uh,
such a, uh, large networks, right?
Second problem would be the computational problem, right?
We'll see that even when we will start
with this VG 16 training.
That one many times, even your
collab notebook on which I'll show you these, uh, uh, demo
may not support in the sense it may support,
but then many times it, uh,
restart the session automatically.
That is what I have experienced.
So resource is another problem,
computational resource, okay?
That you must have some, some GPU support.
If you start training these big networks on the on,
on the CPU and all, then it, it's very difficult, right?
So you see that there are some indications,
it is indicative numbers, it is given that VGD 16
where the number of parameters are 1 38 millions, uh,
you required four Z Ps and four CPUs,
and you will have to train the system for two
to three weeks, then that training training would complete.
Now see, such, uh, what, what a requirement it has.
Similarly, for a res residual network, 50 50 layers,
you may require one week of training with eight gpu, right?
And then, I mean, a similar kind of, uh, stat you will see
for even the transformer based network, like birth GPT
and all, some of them we have seen already, okay?
Like, like you can see here as well.
So, uh, these are some of the regions.
The first region was the,
you would require the largest scale data set,
which you may not have all the time.
Second one would be that high computational cost, right?
And third one would be the
poor performance on low resource domains
and model learn, task specific representation.
And, uh, well, which you cannot reuse if, if, if, uh,
if, uh, every time you try to build it from the scratch.
So the observation is training
such a large network from the scratch requires data
compute and time.
And that is what we don't have all the time, okay?
And that's where this motivational
thought come into the picture.
The suppose now, uh, take a case of VGZ
and we have to start training the VGG, uh,
say VGG 1616 layers.
I'll show you that. Then should we start training it from
the scratch or do we have any other, uh,
other, other way out?
Okay? So the motivation is instead
of training a model from the scratch for each new task,
can we leverage knowledge from the existing models?
Okay? Because if you are training something from the
scratch, uh, such a big, such a big model, spending such a,
such a computational and, uh, computation time
and, uh, all these, all these costs,
then the purpose should be a little bigger.
Rather than solving just one task, your purpose should be
to, to, uh, use the same network
for any other task also in the future, right?
So that should be the purpose.
And if you see, this is what we do as a human being, all
of us, we do in the same way all of us.
We leverage our knowledge, what we have learned in the past,
and apply that for the future tasks.
For example, I have given some of the pointers here,
A person who knows Hindi can quickly learn Marti
because both share the vocabulary and the structure.
And a student, uh, with
who is good in solving the ge physics level, uh,
GE level physics, they can adapt faster
for the engineering mechanics problems.
A, a, a person who has, uh, already learned say
that the cycle, okay, in their childhood, suppose sometimes
or anytime before then it would be easier
for the same person to learn the bike
because now the person knows how to balance the how when
to take left turn with what angle I have to take that
so that I will not fall.
They'll have the traffic sense better.
So all those things helps.
So these are some of the examples,
what you can see from the human's life that how we
as a human, uh,
leverage the knowledge from whatever
we have learned in the past.
And we don't always try
to learn everything from the scratch, right?
In the same way, we can also, uh,
apply this analogy for, for these neural networks,
those neural networks, which are really very big,
like millions of parameters, networks.
We don't have to train them from this scratch all the time.
And the idea where we are leveraging their knowledge
for some other task, some other downstream tasks, that,
that, that learning itself is
known as the transfer learning.
Okay? Now, this much, I guess you all of, uh, all
of us have seen in the previous sessions previous course,
also, this is just a, a recap for all those things.
So if we define what is the transfer learning?
Transfer learning is a machine learning techniques
or paradigms, you can say that
where knowledge gained while solving one problem is applied
to a different but related problems.
Okay? So the, excuse me.
So this is the fundamental difference.
You can see that in the traditional machine learning
and the transfer learning paradigms, in the case
of traditional machine learning, like say that's a model A
and model B, okay?
And both are CNN networks, convolution, neural networks.
And the idea is through the model A, you have learned the,
to identify the shape of triangle.
And with the model B, you have learned
to identify the shape of square.
Okay? This is what, uh, we do traditionally.
Now, that is not the idea of the transfer learning.
The idea of the transfer learning is you take, uh, you, uh,
make this model little bigger, uh, bigger when I say maybe,
uh, bigger in depth, right?
Or maybe bigger in the data while training. Okay?
So this model will suppose
if it'll learn one type of task, say
that identifying the triangle,
then you can utilize the knowledge of this particular model
while pre, while, uh, predicting the, the squares as well.
Okay? Obviously, you may have to do a little bit
of fine tuning at the, at the, uh, later part of the time,
but then you can still leverage the knowledge
of this particular model because if you see carefully while
identifying the, uh, this, this, uh, triangle also it has,
it has, it has somehow learned the, the, the basic
features like edges, that this is one edge,
this is another edge.
This is one other edge. There are three different edges.
They are connecting somehow, giving you a shape.
And that's how it is, it is able to identify
that this is a triangle.
That is what we do at the convolution layer,
that we are trying to, uh, control my, my, uh,
filters or kernels, right?
With a specific size on my image.
And then we get the neighborhood, uh, features instead
of learning the entire entire image at once, right?
That is what we do. And there is that, that is
what it happens at the first layer
and the second layer of the CNN that you learns the edges,
and then the higher layer, you connect those edges,
and then you start getting the object information
or object, uh, object shapes, right?
So in the same way in this particular object also
where you are having some, some squares here also,
you have the ages now instead of three, now you have four on
that, that is the only difference.
But at the lower level, when you start learning the edges,
the same learning can be applied here as well.
Then why? To learn the, the same model from the scratch.
Okay? So that's the idea.
So you can leverage the, the knowledge,
what this model has already learned, say
that identifying the edges,
and then you may have to fine tune a little bit
for the new type of object,
and then the same model will adapt that new task as well.
So that's the idea of the transfer learning.
Now, this transfer learning, uh, uh, uh, what,
what we are going to see that it, it is, uh, roughly,
it can have the two types, okay?
The transfer learning can be the constructive transfer
learning, or it can be inductive transfer learning.
The transfer, uh, which is transfect transfer learning is
where the source task is equal to target task,
but domains differ.
Okay? For example, uh, you are identifying, uh, say
that the, uh, one category of the object,
but now you are trying to identify some
of the category of the object.
That is, that is the difference.
For example, we have just seen, we were trying
to identify the, you can say the triangle,
but now we are trying to identify the squares.
So source task is somehow equivalent
to the target task, right?
But in the inductive transfer learning, what happens,
source are,
source task is not equivalent to the target task.
Okay? And, uh, maybe the, uh,
the example could be the captioning image, captioning fair.
Suppose that this particular model is trained
to identify the object,
but now you are asking from this model
that I'll give you this particular, uh, object,
and you have to tell me, you have
to gimme the caption about this particular object.
Now, that would be completely different task, right?
That would not be the same task
like you're identifying the square, right?
So such kind of, uh, such kind of, uh, uh,
task would be the inductive, uh, uh,
in inductive transfer learning.
It'll, there, it'll fall.
Both the things are possible,
but we'll see that how, how, uh,
we can, we can do it, right?
So I, I take one example now, SBA,
just explaining about the BG 16.
So usually what happen in the case of the transfer learning,
you use the model, uh, you use the model.
And then, um, first of all, you built the skeleton
of the model, and there is a pre-training step.
There is a pre-training steps.
For example, in the case of VGZ, the, you, you, you, uh,
the, the authors utilize the image data set where you,
we had the 1.2 millions of images
from the thousand different classes, right?
So what they did, so, uh, they, uh, pre-trained
or we say that they trained the model
with those thousand classes, okay?
And this was the structure of the VG 16. Okay?
Uh, it is just a different representation,
but this is the structure and why it is VG 16,
because there are 16 layers.
So you just ignore the pooling layer.
You and, uh, just count it.
You will find that there are 16 layers.
So two layers of convolution here, two layers
of convolution here, three here, three here, three here.
So two plus two, four plus three,
seven plus three 10 plus three 13.
And after this, you, uh,
they use three different dense layer.
So 13 plus 13, 13 plus 360.
That's why, uh, the, the name which G 16.
But they also had different versions of the VG 16,
which we had already seen, right?
So I'll show you with this VGA 16 that how
to utilize this VGA 16
and then train, uh, train for some other tasks.
So I, uh, once again, I'll repeat this particular, uh, uh,
this particular model was trained for thousand
class classification problem,
thousand class classification problem.
And the input was, uh, input,
total input size was 1.2 millions
of images from the image set.
Right? Now, what we have to do when we have
to adopt this model for some of the task,
we can adopt it in two ways.
The first way, uh, for the first one
and the usual way is known as the feature extraction,
and the second way is known as the fine tuning.
Okay? Now, what is the meaning of it?
So you just see that these two pictures
that will gi give you a little more clarity.
So in the the left side, it is showing the, uh,
feature extraction way where we have trained our VG 16.
Consider that this model is VG 16 model. Okay?
So what we did, we trained this model on the ImageNet data
set, and this model is, is, is, is trained
to predict the thousand class classification problem.
Fine. Now, this is a pre-training time.
What we do is we, uh, what they did is from this V 16,
they divided this whole architecture into two parts, up
to this particular layer.
They say they set it at, it is a convolution layer,
and then we have the fully connected layer.
So this part, they set it as a,
this is a feature extraction part, okay?
Because usually the convolution layer is used
to extract the features from the images.
So at the first level, they might be extracting the, uh,
edges features, very low level features.
Then at the second level,
they might be combining those edges
and the third level from those edges,
they're making some kind of shape.
And the fourth level, maybe from that shape,
they're making some kind of a structure,
and that's how they're identifying the object.
So you see that in the, the idea in the PG 16
and adding many convolution layer is to start
with very low level features
and keep on a building on that to get the object, uh,
which you are able to identify at the output layer.
So what they did, if you're using this particular model
for the, for as a feature extraction, what you can do
that up to this particular layer, you can, you can use
as a feature extraction.
And then whatever layer you have at the last,
like three trends layer they used in the original VVGG
network, this layer you can redefine by yourself.
And that is what you can see here,
the feature extraction part or the all the VGG
or the CNN convolution layer,
that is a feature extraction layer that you can use as it is
and extract the features from that particular, uh, uh, that,
uh, that particular, uh, feature extractor layers.
And you add your own model, train a new model
for the new task, whatever you want to predict, okay?
We'll do this, we'll do this particular, I'll show you that
how exactly to do with the VG 16,
with the fashion adminis data set,
which we have been using from last couple of classes right
now, there is a other way of adopting the same layer.
And this, this, uh, this way is known as fine tuning. Okay?
Now fine tuning obviously here also you do,
you train the model, but fine tuning when I say I meant
that whatever is your original model.
So this is the original model where you have the 13 layers
of convolution followed by three layers of fully connection.
Okay? So this is the original VG 16.
Consider this one then in the fine tuning what we do,
because the task is completely new, maybe the features,
what you're expecting from here may help,
may not help, we don't know.
But because task is say
that completes completely new site like image captioning
and such kind of task,
this original VE 16 was never trained, you may have
to fine tune the feature extractor part also.
Okay? That is the main idea.
So this is a feature extractor part where the convolution,
uh, layer you can see.
So this is the feature extractor part I'm saying.
And the idea in the case of fine tuning is you may have to
learn maybe some of the convolution layer
or all the convolution layer as well, okay?
It depends on what kind of data
or whether it is able to adopt that or not.
That, that it depends and that you can, uh, that, that,
that we have to try one by one by unfreezing these layers
and training these layers at the, uh,
fine tuning time, right?
But these are the two ways you can say
that in which you can adopt the models knowledge,
earlier knowledge for the new task,
what you want to perform.
Okay? So once again,
there are two steps in the transfer learning.
So because these networks are very big, the idea is
to not train these networks every time from the scratch,
millions of parameter.
We need not to train and we don't have such
a big data set also.
So if you go on training such millions of parameter network
for the small data set, what we have,
you will fall into another problem, okay?
That problem will be the over fitting problem, right?
Because the network is so deep,
it'll again go into the over problem.
So just to ignore that, what we have done is you said
that the one way of adopting the knowledge of this network
is to use the con up to convolution layer
as a feature extractor layer.
And then we will change this classification layer
where we have the three dense, uh,
fully connected layer, right?
The other ways, if the task is completely different,
you see, then you can unfreeze some
of these convolution layer as well,
and then you can see that whether the same model is able
to adopt for the new task, what you're trying to do or not.
Okay? So this is what I was telling.
So you can just, uh, freeze the first part of the network.
This part is known as feature extract extractor,
and then you can add your own neural network.
You can add your own neural network, right?
And this would work in the case
where your new task is similar to the task,
what V six 16 has already seen at the pre-training time.
That is called object classification,
uh, classification problem, right?
But then suppose the task is, uh, suppose the task is, uh,
completely new, say that image captioning, okay?
Which say that the VG 16 has not seen at the pre-training
time, then it, it is possible
that here adding just a fully connected layer will not help.
Okay? You may have to unfreeze some of the conation here,
I've shown, okay, only the last, these,
these three layers are being, uh, unfreeze, okay?
But it is possible that, uh, you may have to unfreeze this,
these three also or these three also,
or maybe complete architecture as well, okay?
And you have to retrain it from the scratch.
This is possible, but, uh, uh, uh,
but, uh, uh, if the task is completely different,
then only we go with the fine tuning.
Otherwise we go with the feature extraction mode of model
adoption, right?
So, uh, what we are, uh, uh,
what we will do is we will take one, uh, use case,
use case is same like what we would, uh, uh,
what we have taken in the earlier classes
that fashion adminis data set,
where we have the 10 class classification problem.
And we will do this version, the feature extraction version,
because this version is expensive as well as, uh, uh,
because you will start training this one, it'll,
it'll be time taken and all.
So we can do this, it's not a problem,
but then we will start understanding the transfer learning
concept from this feature extraction.
So before moving into that, let us understand this part
that why this transfer learning will work.
As I said, the core idea is
to learn the generic feature first
and then task specific features later.
Okay? So what happens in the case of a 16,
the early layers like these, these layers, con one,
one con one, two, what you're seeing
con two, one, con two, two.
So these are the early layers.
It learns the generic visual features like edges,
the corners, the textures, right?
And the middle layers, like you can, uh,
you can treat this con 3, 1, 4, 1
as the middle layers, right?
So these layers will learn the parts
and shape, they will connect those edges,
they'll connect those edge with the corner, right?
So, uh, that is what they'll learn at the middle layer
and the, at the later layer, later layer, right?
Uh, uh, I was talking about this like say the ripped layer
here, it'll learn the task, a specific concept,
whether it is a classification problem
or image captioning problem
or boundary, uh, identifying what,
how many objects are there, many, many kinds
of problems you may have in the
case of image as well, right?
So, uh, the last layer,
later layer would be highly dependent on the target data
set, but the initial layers may have the,
maybe may capture the similar kind of features,
and hence, you should be this transfer learning concept
will work, okay?
Because if you talk about the image, what you have,
you may have the images in whatever kind
of image you will see as an input.
You all, you will always have some kind ofs in that image.
And those, those initial level features are mostly same.
And that's why this transfer learning concept works,
because initial level features, whatever types
of network you will generate,
they'll start from there itself.
And these networks are already good with that.
Then why not leverage their knowledge as it is instead
of building our own.
So that's the concept, and
that's why the transfer learning works.
So earlier, middle layers capture the universal visual
patterns, and these patterns are useful
across dataset and task.
Hence, we freeze those layers
and that's why I've shown here these layers are
freeze, okay?
And then you can train the last layer
or sometimes the, some convolution layer as well based on
what kind of task you're performing, okay?
Now what we'll see is, we'll see the demo, okay?
Demo for this VG 16
for this fashion data asset classification.
And as I said, we'll see the first version
that is called this version
where feature extraction part will freeze.
We will not train these
because we are not going to train millions of parameters.
That is, it is difficult to also to show in the class
and may maybe our, our system may not support that, uh,
to training it from the scratch, right?
So we will, what we'll do is we'll freeze all these layers
and we'll, we'll make our own neural network neural network.
When I say we'll also build here the fully connected neur
also, but this neural network can be anything.
For example, if it is a image captioning task, it's possible
that instead of building the fully connected layer,
you can add here the recurrent neural network, okay?
RNN, you'll learn it later,
but the R ns are good for the sequential outputs.
So it is possible that,
but here we will be building the, uh, classification, um,
uh, classification layer.
And for classification,
the fully connected dense network is sufficient,
and that is what we are going to do as well.
Okay? So let us first understand, uh, the workflow,
what we are going to use.
So we are going to reuse a pre-trained V 16 model,
and we are going to adapt it
for the fashion adminis classification task.
And that task, we have the 10 different classes.
So we'll not have a thousand different classes.
We'll see that we have only 10 different classes.
So the workflow would be something like this.
So first we are going to load the VG 16.
So where is the V 16 available?
So it is available with the PyTorch.
So if you see here, if you'll just type the, uh,
VG 16 PyTorch, this is what this is,
what is the page you will get?
Okay? So the VG 16 is available with the torch vision
inside the PyTorch.
So if you will, uh, I will show you,
if you'll import this torch vision, then we can easily, uh,
load this VG 16 model as it is what, uh, the 16 layers
of the Vge six VG model.
Fine. So this is the first thing what we'll do that, uh,
uh, we'll first load this V 16 model, which is trained
with the ImageNet data set.
Then what we'll do is we'll separate the feature
extractor and classifier.
That is what I was telling you here.
This is the, uh, feature extractor.
This whole part is a feature extractor,
and this part is my classifier, right?
So in the original V 16, this was, this is how it was.
So we'll separate this part from this part
because this part, I want to change this classifier part.
I want to change based on my task.
That is a 10 class classification problem
of fashion adminis data set.
Okay? So that is what we'll do as a second strip,
separate the feature extracted and classifier,
and then what we'll do is we'll replace the classifier
for the fashion, as I said.
Uh, as as, as we, we are separating the classifier, we have
to build our own classifier,
and that is what we are going to build fine,
then we'll freeze the feature extract layer
because we don't want to train the, uh, uh, the,
what is the, the weights, which is
inside the feature extract part, okay?
And we'll train only the new classifier.
We'll train only the new classifier. And why this work?
As I said, VE 16 already learns a powerful image,
visual features from the image that, so whatever kind
of image, the initial level features, whatever you want,
maybe that VE 16 will be able to give you.
And then you can just put your own classifier
and we'll see that how much good, how much, uh,
accuracy it is able to give.
Okay? So if you, if I'll go one level down, uh, in the sense
that if, I'll show you the VG 16, uh,
it is 1.2 million images.
Okay? Uh, just a second.
Okay. So, uh, if, if you see that
how the, uh, VG 16 all has shown you in the form of table,
this is how it looks like in the sense that the input image
in, in, um, this, uh, uh,
ImageNet data set, which is, which is given as an input
to this,
okay?
Maybe I'll explain this one. I'll stop that.
Uh, the, the coding part I'll show you in the next class.
So, uh, the input image was given,
the input MS size was 2 24 across 2 24 across three.
The T three channel, the RGP, uh, the red, green,
and blue, the colored image was the input further
for this particular model.
Okay? Now if you see the first two convolution
layer, this is how it was.
They used three cross, three size kernel,
I mean the filter, right?
And they applied how many such filter,
the 64 such filters they have used.
And they obviously, they have applied the radio activation
function, the, the way we have learned the, uh,
convolutional layer.
So there is a three cross three filter,
which will convolve on our 2 24 cross, 2 24 cross image,
whatever will be the output that will add the bias into it,
and then it'll be followed by the radio activation function.
Okay? How many such filters? 64. Okay?
And then again, after this,
there is one more convolution layer
and uh, the, again, three cross three filter.
Uh, in fact, SAR already explained in the vge 16, they,
they, while they doing the experiment, they said that,
that they have used across the layer only the one type
of filter that is three across three.
Obviously they have trained the number
of filters from here to here.
You can see 64, 1 28 to 56, 5, 12, and five 12.
That is how they're varied.
But the size of the filter was same.
The max pooling layer at was also almost same.
They use the window to cross two.
And the stride was also two, stride was also two. Okay?
So one thing, uh, before, I'll explain you this one.
In the next class, in the whole conal uh, neural network
or this VG network, if you will see, we,
you have the weights at the con
whenever, wherever you see
that there is a convolution layer there,
you have the weights, the filters were the weight,
these three cross three, the weights,
these three cross three, the weights.
So how many weights at this layer three, cross three
and 64, such filters.
So 64 cross three, cross three,
these many parameters you have at this layer,
similar 64 cross three cross three parameters.
At this layer here you have 1 28 cross,
three cross three parameters at this layer, okay?
And so on. You can see that here you have 4 0 9 6, uh,
in fact seven cross seven cross five 12 in 2 4 0 9 6
parameter, then 4 0 9 6 in 2 4 0 9 6 parameter
and 4 0 9 6 in 2000 parameters.
And altogether, if you will add it is it was having the
parameters in uh, millions.
Okay? That is what we have seen. Okay?
So, uh, the idea is to freeze this particular layer.
This, this is called feature extract layer
and do not train this layer.
And here you add your own fully connected layer
for the 10 class classification problem.
So first of all, we will see that once we load this one,
this model, we'll divide this into two part feature
extracted part from the classifier part,
and then we will add our own classifier.
See, this whole feature extractor part will be as it is,
but we'll add our own classifier.
Now you see the difference here we have 4 0 9 6, 4 0 9 6
and thousand in the original V 16 fully
connected layer neurons.
But now what we will do, we will, uh,
we will use only 1 0 2 4, then five 12,
and we will, uh, we'll use at the last layer only 10 T, but
because we have 10 class classification problem, okay?
This is what is the change we'll see that we'll do,
and uh, we are going
to freeze this whole feature extract part,
and we are going to update only this much parameters.
So here the parameters would be seven,
cross seven into five 12.
This is the inputs going to 1 0 2 4 neurons.
So those many parameters and 1 0 2 4 into five 12
and five 12 into 10.
Obviously you have to add the biases.
So these mini parameters only we are going to interest,
all the parameters will be fixed.
Okay? So this, uh, let me stop here.
Uh, I'll show you the, uh, the, the demo in the next class,
but, uh, if you have any question till this particular
point, uh, you can ask us.
So then you will able to, uh, you will understand that
how the CNN networks initially what we learned was, uh,
later on expanded with this, uh, bigger networks
and how these networks through, uh,
training those networks was difficult.
So this transfer learning came into the picture
and they set, set this idea that all the time you don't have
to train these bigger network from the scratch.
And in fact, you can leverage their knowledge for the
whatever new task with a little bit of fine tuning.
Okay? So you please ask the questions if you have any,
and then we'll stop you,
Sir. One, one
question. So we are using three by three, uh, kers
or filters, um, uh, 64 such filters.
And uh, we are increasing that to five 12.
So how many possible filters can be there?
Like we are using, um, we are using a three by three matrix
of, uh, nine values.
And uh, if we are using only zero one,
I think it's like five 12 possibilities.
So that's the maximum number of filters
that we can add. Uh, no,
No, you, you can in fact add more than this itself
because here it is only 16 layers.
So if you see the 19 layers of EGG there, it, there, there,
there, there, the maybe combination would be
even more than five 12.
It's up to you how many filters you want to add.
So, so the filter values, right?
Um, they can be filter values
Are weights, I mean that you learn
with the back propagation.
We don't have to bother about what are the weights.
You can start initializing anything between say zero to one
and with the back propagation anyway, you will learn that
like you learn in the fully connected layer.
So they, they can be even um, um, dismal values in between
Anything. Yes, yes, definitely
yes, yes.
Okay, sir. Yeah, Okay.
So we don't have to, uh, bother about, okay,
what is those nine values?
The filter means three or three metrics.
What are those nine values
that you can randomly analyze Anything?
You can start with 1, 0, 0 0.1.
Anything between minus one, two plus one, everything is okay
because you are going to do the back propagation
and all those value you are going to exist.
Yeah.
Okay. Thank you sir. Yeah,
Sir. One more question sir.
So this is with respect
to the context of computer vision, sir.
So in case of LLM, how do we fit into one hot encoding,
uh, into this CN sir?
Oh, so, uh, uh, we'll explain if possible the case
of text data.
So, so usually what happens,
the text data is a 1D data, okay?
Like image is a, uh, 2D data
and uh, uh, the text is a 1D data.
So the only difference you'd see the convolution operation,
the way you drew the conation is different in the case
of text as compared to the, uh, image.
So in the case of text, you do, uh,
the one dimension conation, you go from top to down,
you don't go, don't go from left to right
and then top to bottom.
Okay? So there is a difference in the conation operation,
but then conation operation, uh, you can do there also
with the one one 1D, 1D convolution.
That is what we apply here.
I'll show you in the code we do the 2D convolution
and that is what we have seen in the earlier classes also.
So that is the main difference. Rest of the things are same.
So what we do is we start the input with the one hot encoder
and then we put one embedding layer.
We get our embedded vector
as an input in the form of metrics.
And in that metrics, each role represent a word.
Each role TA word that becomes our metrics
and that we convolve on, on that metrics itself.
We start coning. Yeah.
Okay. Thank you. Okay.
Any other query? Is the concept
of transfer learning only for CNN related model?
We can do it for other models? No,
No, no. In
fact, the first slide I showed, it is true
for any types of network.
I mean, in fact, you can build your own network,
a very small network, maybe three layer, five layer,
and you can save the, the weight, you can save the model
and you can utilize the same model for the next password.
It is true that the, the concept itself can be valued
for any kind of network,
but usually you do it for, for the bigger networks
where the training from the scratch is not always
a convenient task.
Yeah. Okay.
Okay. Any other query from anyone?
So, uh, Bimal, what we can do is we,
we can announce in the LMS that uh, they will have the exam
on Saturday in the given slot, maybe nine
to 10, right?
And, uh, whoever would be left,
we can take their tests separately.
We'll see that when, when the common
slot we can give for that.
Okay. And sir portion is whatever has been taught till
now or till
Now? Till
today. Till today, yes. Okay.
And it's MCQ or coding, sir? M-C-Q-M-C. Okay sir. Thank you.
Yes.
Alright, then let us meet on Saturday,
Okay? Yes, sir.
Sir. Good sir. Thank you, sir.
Thank you sir. Sir. Good night sir. Thank you.